hello hello
i'm so happy to be here i'm the honored
one
because i'm a huge fan of you ever since
you're being a baby i
am so excited that you are here for so
many reasons i didn't know how much you
were trained in like
kafka and dostoyevsky and mammoth
all of this heavy drama and then you
come on to the scene and you steal our
hearts
but more incredible you
break through and get nominated for a
comedic performance
at the academy awards which is just
notoriously
impossible you did it i'm so
impressed i'm so happy for you
i wish i could say it just like borat i
mean
first of all i love your transformation
that's one of the funnest things to do
as an actor
you did it so well you go from not to
hot
and like that just sounds silly but it
was a real transformation
did you mark in your script did you make
choices did you really think about how
to go from one extreme to the other
oh it's been really interesting but the
whole team that worked on board
has been full of professionalists and i
own everything to
probably my makeup artist katie frey
about my
visual site um because she is
unbelievable artist she's been working
with prosthetics and with
amazing makeup back in the day uh so she
created my facial hair because as much
as i tried to curl my facial hair
it never grow up um but my body hair
instead of my facial
crew completely it's been interesting
because from this wild crazy
uh village girl to the she's becoming a
super
right-wing journalist with blonde hair
along here i mean i'm not naturally
blonde i'm
bleached now and
it's been it's been extreme it's been
interesting but it's
this character that it's somewhere in
the middle and i'm super happy that
we're ending
the movie with tuta having a short
haircut because she
is a feminist and she's strong
independent woman
that doesn't define herself as a woman
just because of her hair
and i was thinking about that before
because here sometimes for women it's
really really important because
it's like secret weapon we're hiding
ourselves behind
here but when you take it off you feel
naked but at the same time super
powerful
no matter how much vulnerable you can be
it's like a
different way of strength so it's
different
i think that kind of intelligence behind
the character really pays off because
you know you do really grow in the film
but i also think that there's a
tremendous amount of heart
to your character which is also what's
being
recognized and awarded and i love your
relationship with sasha baron cohen
who's also nominated
for the trial of chicago seven and i you
know
he has broken through the adam sandler's
jim carrey you know sasha they're all
known for comedy and when they break
through
into drama it's so exciting to see that
diversity
in their talents but i just already
anticipate you guys
seeing each other at the evening you
guys have such a lovely connection he
was really
parental to you in this role i mean he
plays your dad
but you guys have this wonderful
chemistry together
what was that like working with him ah
it's been extremely inspiring because
sasha is a superhero he's extremely
smart it's kind of scary how smart he is
because
he has a feeling that his brain never
stopped working it's like click click
click click click like a cloak
and there is always potentially a better
idea a better joke so the script was
ever
evolving with the greatest team that you
can imagine
and we had three women writing to this
uh to this
storyline and um he's a genius
he is a genius it's insane but there is
an insane amount of intelligence to what
he has brought to the world starting
from
ali g and into borat into
many of the characters he's played and
this film
is boy does it have a lot of commentary
on the world we live in i have to ask
you about the scene with rudy giuliani
holy cow what was that moment like
and could it have gone farther if sasha
hadn't stepped in
i was hoping that maybe scene will go in
a different direction because
the more i think about the more i
realized that for me as maria
is about how men sometimes most
times unfortunately treat women and that
this equality that we're fighting for
and i hope my generation will start
demanding
is unfortunately not there yet and but
we have to work for it
uh to create it because women
a lot of times have been seen as sexual
objects
and that's not really the right thing to
be done
because i'm thinking about um maybe
he would have behaved differently if i
was a man journalist
i was relieved when sasha stepped in
because i'm like even though he's like
in a teddy
you know and like in this hilarious
outfit it brings like a sigh of relief
because it just seems like it could have
gone the distance it
you guys pushed the envelope so far in
this film
and i'm so happy for you that it is
being recognized
in a way that i think a drama typically
would
it's a serious movie filled with a lot
of commentary
a lot of exploration and examination of
society
and women and men and i i mean
i'm really grateful for what you put out
into the world and i'm grateful for how
it's being received
i do want to see our movie it is a riot
against misogyny and against subjugating
women but
at the same time not with like this is
so bad this is so wrong
just it's gonna guide you to the way
that you will be okay so maybe next time
i'm gonna think before do something um
because it does revealing people's true
colors and
we all need to to do that i think i hope
well i completely completely agree
now speaking of men of comedy who
never lack heart you're working with
judd apatow right now
and i believe he might have told you
about your nomination
yes he did um i was on set with the
amazing jet apatow and the great pedro
pascal because we had a scene
where you were actually able to see my
hand on camera and it was shaking
because i knew that at 12 20
they're gonna announce the nominations
and in the morning judd asked me
so today they're going to announce them
do you want to separate yourself and
watch
the show and here eventually what is
going to happen i was like no no no
please let's work less work
this is already a win i'm here i'm
working with you
i'm around an amazing team let's just
keep shooting
so we were keep shooting and right next
to me was the camera
and the screen of the camera and i was
able to see what time is it and it was
10 05 at 1205
12 10. uh like that and
12 20 i start looking at people and
trying to make a contact eye contact
with them to see
are they know something is it gonna be a
good news it's gonna be i mean it's
already good news
so he came closer and i was like he's
gonna tell me in my ear
to not embarrass me in front of the
other people in front of the team
and he was like look at the camera you
just got your nomination for the academy
i think i lost my mind and i i don't
even remember did i jumped or did they
fall on the floor it is it is
one of these moments when you feel like
you're in a different dimension it is
insane uh so it's
he is amazing and i cannot believe that
i was able to share this special moment
with him
well can you tell me anything about this
movie i'm such a judd apatow fan
i'm freaking out i love him so much i'm
too
and um so the movie is gonna follow the
story of actors that are gonna try to
finish a movie during the pandemic
it's not gonna feel like a pandemic
movie and something that is gonna feel
us make us feel
bad it's gonna feel more like a holiday
movie because it's
a lot of people um that are gonna
make you feel harm-warmed heart-warmed
yeah he he never lacks heart that's why
i love him
i'm so excited to see the jud apatow
movie and everything that you do
and make sure to check out borah
subsequent movie film if you haven't
already
because everybody has it's on amazon
prime
and good luck on sunday we'll be
cheering you on